Hilary Clinton is on a new book tour and
she's gone after President Trump watch
this
I believe he knows he's an illegitimate
president he knows he knows that there
were a bunch of different reasons why
the election turned out the way it did
and I take responsibility for those
parts of it that I should and so I know
that he knows that this wasn't on the
level I don't know that we'll ever know
everything that happened so of course
he's obsessed with me and I believe that
it's a guilty conscience in so much as
he has a conscience the book gutsy women
favorite stories of courage and
resilience
Hillary co-author is her own daughter
Chelsea Clinton they're appearing
tonight Jesse and Brooklyn you want to
go with me Turner that one I can't wait
to tear into that oh my god listen she's
crooked person and for her to finger
Trump is being crooked his complete
hypocrisy talk about foreign
interference and election how about all
those tens of millions of dollars that
poured into the Clinton Foundation when
she was Secretary of State or running
for president it was that influencing
the election at all or that nine million
dollars she paid a foreign agent
influenced the last election called the
steel dossier she's a total joke and
she's a total hypocrite but she may see
an opening because Biden hasn't answered
basic questions like why Biden did your
brother win a billion dollar contract to
build homes in Iraq from no experience
or how'd your son leave China with a
billion dollars on Air Force two hasn't
answered those questions Hillary might
be seeing an opening here what do you
think well I do believe that she has
repeatedly called out the President on
things that she disagrees with him but
this is a new level of attack going
after her emails after all of the months
and years of investigations remember
when the Republicans control the house
we had the Benghazi investigation we had
all kinds of investigations until
Hillary Clinton but I'm looking forward
to reading this book because she's
talking about gutsy women including
Republican women like Margaret chase
Smith Gregg what about you you wanted
yes I you know I always loved a book on
female empowerment I just find it a bad
message that it took two women to write
I feel like Hillary has only one world
to live in yeah and she has nowhere else
to go she's like a drunk loitering
outside a bar waiting for it to open and
that bar isn't the presidency and she
may be right she may be right that when
she's looking at this terrain and she's
seeing a bunch of like supporting
characters but no main lead my question
is okay she does enter okay she's got to
be calculating the risk what if she
enters and she pulls less than Joe and
less than Liz that's the risk of being
humiliated however she doesn't want that
first line in her bitchu airy to be I
lost a trump twice lost electoral
college she won the popular vote but I
don't think to use the phrase me
hyperbole Donna she says yes which she
says that this election is illegitimate
that's hyperbole and that and you know
elections exist to prevent war that's
how we don't we don't have civil wars we
don't have coos we have elections but
when you start saying these elections
don't matter she's actually pushing it
towards conflict not anybody else I
think that just in listening to her and
having you here for your expertise on
this in your experience that the loser
of the election the one who concedes is
usually the one that they had those I
have the heartache they have all that
loss that they have to go through and so
somebody like Al Gore for example after
the recount he did not do this type of
thing to say that the Bush presidency
was illegitimate he moved on he went and
he moved to California he had he had
pursuits and documentaries and climate
change and I just wonder about the
decision to constantly question the
legitimacy of an election and how
dangerous that is I remember that night
when Al Gore called and says shut it
down meaning shut down the campaign
after the Supreme Court ruled but we're
now in a different era will
the disruption that started years ago
continues nobody wants to concede
anymore we want to continue the next
fight and this this campaign now it's
going to be another exercise of what I
call gutter politics but what do you
think about Hillary writing a new book
when her daughter gutsy women um well I
think it's wonderful any project with
your mom is is wonderful and especially
for this I don't have that opportunity
so that's that's fantastic I think that
her book tour epic ISM her book core is
interesting in that you ever since the
election when her favorability rate
plummeted she has less than favorability
rate of one third with independents none
with Republicans and it went down 11%
with Democrats after the election in
2016 and it has not risen so this book
tour especially since she continues
residing in victimhood land it won't do
her any favors and it reminded me of
just being like in a sorority again
where she was like clearly he's obsessed
with me but Donald Trump is her one
obsession whereas she is just one of his
many topics rent-free and Donald Trump
said look what I do know and I haven't
read the book yet let everybody go
without paying rent through that but
what I like about is that she is going
to live up all of these unknown women
many of them who are not really known to
the public and tell their stories all
this money to charity right oh well you
know of course she's gonna make sure
that the money spread very well